[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
31 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with Mark Mandel, my colleague.
How are you doing, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing well, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm pretty well.
I'm very happy
with the interview
we're going to be having today
with one of our colleagues
working here in the San
Francisco office, Eli Bixby.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's going
to be a really interesting
discussion on TensorFlow.
We're going to go
quite deep on it.
I think it's going to be fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, you're going
to learn about, among
all the things, why
is it called TensorFlow.
I didn't know, actually, so
I learned something today.
And after that, we're going
to be talking about big data,
but not how to process it, but
how to upload really big data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, what do you
do when you have lots of data
that you want to
give to Google Cloud?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so we're going
to be talking about
the couple of options
that we have available for
you if you have, I don't know,
terabytes, or
petabytes, or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
lots and lots of data.
But first, we've got our
cool thing of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
it is very cool this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
we just-- literally,
just as we were recording this--
announced the Google Cloud
Platform education grants.
Or for those less
Australian, grants.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: This is a
pretty cool endeavor.
I'm very excited about it.
Basically, currently it only
applies to the United States,
but we're hoping to expand
it internationally soon, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Soon.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, soon.
But basically, yeah,
if you're looking
to use Google Cloud Platform
in your educational institution
and you want to have
free Cloud Credits-- say
that three times quickly-- free
Cloud Credits for your students
to be able to use the
resources of Google Cloud,
we now offer you the
ability to apply for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and it is
very cool because so far we've
been doing it for,
in some specific--
and actually, we have
a link to the blog post
where we announced the
educational program-- but one
of the links is actually
Cloud for Cancer.
And I was reading about it.
I thought it was very cool.
It was basically like
a neural network.
And if you don't know what a
neural network is, don't worry.
We're going to be talking
about it in a minute.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But basically,
a neural network that
allows doctors to upload
the properties of a melanoma
and detect if it is
malignant or not.
So basically, it is trying
to provide very good, very
high quality information.
I think that they
mention they have
like 99.9% accuracy for doctors
all around the world, which
is pretty awesome.
And it runs for
free on App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: There's
a couple other things
that I quite like about this.
One, it's not just a,
hey, here's some stuff,
do with it as you will.
There is also documentation
for students and teachers
that's provided, so there's
some extra resources
you have to help teach
this to the students.
As well as that,
faculty sponsors
of technology focus groups
such as Women Techmakers,
Google Developer
groups, et cetera,
are also able to apply as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is pretty awesome.
And for those that don't
have access to it yet,
don't forget that if you
want to give it a try
there's also the
free trial program.
So you have, I think
it's three months.
During three months you have--
MARK MANDEL: 60
days, $300, I think
was the last time
I looked at it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, $300, 60 days,
which is not three
months, it is two months.
But yeah, check it out,
and if you're interested
we'll have a link
on the show notes
so you can apply
directly, and maybe
be one of the lucky first
ones to get our grants.
MARK MANDEL: That
would be great.
Awesome, well, why don't
we go have a chat with Eli
and talk about TensorFlow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool,
let's start with him.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Today we are joined
by Eli Bixby.
He has happily agreed to
grace us with his presence.
How are you doing today, Eli?
ELI BIXBY: I'm doing great.
MARK MANDEL: Eli,
Why don't you tell us
a little bit about who you are
and what you do here at Google.
ELI BIXBY: Great, so
I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google.
I work on Google Cloud Platform
and, specifically, the big data
and machine learning offerings.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
what is a developer programs
engineer in one sentence.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, that's a
hard task, but I'll try.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We could do
an episode on that one day.
ELI BIXBY: So we write
code to teach users
how to use the Platform.
So this code may end
up in blog posts,
in tutorials and workshops, or
it may end up on the website.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool,
so we have you here today
because we wanted to discuss
a little bit about TensorFlow.
But before we start
talking about TensorFlow,
for all the audience that
have never done any machine
learning, what is-- TensorFlow,
I've heard, is neural networks.
What is a neural network?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, so TensorFlow
is mainly for neural networks.
A neural network
in general is, you
can think of it sort of like
as a directed graph, where
the nodes are simply arithmetic
activations of their inputs.
So there are some
nodes upstream,
they feed into a
downstream node,
and the node has a single output
based on the upstream nodes.
And it was sort of
discovered a long time ago,
like in the '70s, that
you could use these
and you could use
back propagation,
which just basically says, I
want the top layer of nodes
to have this certain-- or
I want the output layer
to have a certain output
when the top layer has
a certain input.
And you can use back propagation
to adjust the function
that each node operates on to
line up with these outputs,
and that you can model
very complex functions
with many layers
of neural networks.
MARK MANDEL: Where did
this idea come from?
Do you know any of the history
of how it sort of came about?
ELI BIXBY: I'm not sure.
I think it was
actually originally
sort of a theoretical attempt
to model human cognition, which
is why it's neural networks.
I'm not sure that that
is part of its usage now,
but I think that's where
the name came from.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so just to try
to understand a bit a better
what neural networks are,
basically, at the
end of the day what
you have is a bunch of
nodes, and every note is
like a function where you
get bunch of parameters
and an output.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, and
the nodes are actually
really a helpful
extract abstraction
for us to think about
it, but it's actually--
TensorFlow is named TensorFlow
because its tensor is flowing
along a graph.
And really, you think
of it as the layers
are single entities that are
tensor transformations from one
to the next layer.
And so often we talk about
layers and the activation
function of a layer
of the tensor graph
rather than individual nodes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, So now we know
what TensorFlow
comes from, the name.
Why is TensorFlow a thing?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah,
so TensorFlow is
the successor to Google's
previous machine learning
framework.
And really, the reason
it's open sourced
is we believe that there is
going to be a lot of innovation
in machine learning,
and we think
it's important for these tools
to sort of be standardized
and for work to be shared among
the machine learning community.
And so having a common
framework for expressing machine
learning algorithms
is really important.
So previously you'd see papers,
and you'd see people kind of
informally describe
the algorithm
that they were writing
about, but now you
can actually publish
the code and it's
another step towards
reproducible research,
it allows people to
collaborate more easily,
all the great things we
love about open source.
MARK MANDEL: So
you touched on it
a little bit when you started
talking about tensors flowing
through a graph, but can we
break that down even further?
What's a tensor?
How does this work?
Give us sort of like a
base level understanding.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah,
so mathematicians
are going to hate me
for this definition,
but a tensor is a
multi-dimensional matrix.
So you think of a vector as
just a list of numbers, right?
So like an array in Python.
And a matrix, then, is a
list of lists of numbers,
and so a tensor is-- a vector
is one dimensional tensor,
a matrix is a two
dimensional tensor,
and then a matrix of vectors
is a three dimensional tensor.
And you can expand that
and you get this concept
of shape, which is a
vector that represents
the shape of a tensor.
And so for the users
who've used NumPy
before this should be a
very familiar concept.
TensorFlow actually follows
the exact same syntax
that NumPy does for
defining these things.
MARK MANDEL: And so how
does that correlate into how
we do machine learning?
Like, why is that important?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, so
it's really important
in particular for deep
learning because a lot
of these algorithms
can be thought
of as a series of
tensor computations.
And there's a lot
of optimization
you can also do restricting
the data that's flowing along
your graph to tensors.
So if you compare it with
something like a Apache
Beam or Spark, where there's
sort of arbitrary data flowing
along your computation
graph and you
can define your
own serialization
and de-serialization,
TensorFlow, by contrast,
is all in memory and
calls out to very fast see
implementations of
these tensor operations.
And obviously, that allows
you to plug into Cuda
and use GPUs really easily.
So restricting it to tensors
gets us a lot of functionality.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Interesting, so you actually
mention GPUs, because I'm
assuming that GPUs are better
suited for these
kind of competitions,
but we also announced
this other thing, TPUs.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, so
the strength of GPUs
actually ties a
lot into why we're
seeing a resurgence
in neural networks,
is the techniques have
been around for a long time
and now we have this
commodity hardware that's just
fantastic for neural networks.
And we're seeing neural
networks be extremely useful
in all of these
applications, and so we're
seeing a huge growth, and we're
actually getting to the point
where it makes sense to
have actually have ASICs
for TensorFlow.
So that's what a TPU is.
MARK MANDEL: What's an ASIC?
ELI BIXBY: An ASIC is, I think
the acronym is application
specific integrated chip.
So it's a custom
piece of hardware
that-- and the optimization
you're looking for,
because we have these big
data centers, the optimization
you're looking for is
performance per watt.
So they allow you
to do the operations
that are common in machine
learning at a lower power,
and that means you get a
higher throughput because you
can run a lot more of them for
the same amount of electricity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so it sounds
like TensorFlow is kind of a
complicated and pretty complex
framework.
Does that mean that
to get started with it
I need to understand what
tensors and monads are?
ELI BIXBY: No, so that the
actual goal is that developers
can start writing machine
learning algorithms
and start incorporating
machine learning easily
into their code, and that's
a huge goal of TensorFlow.
So TensorFlow itself, there's
a lot you can do with it.
You can write custom operations.
You can fiddle around
with the internals,
but we try to provide a high
level interface for people
who don't necessarily
want to do that,
and we're actually looking at
building more layers on top
of TensorFlow to make
it easier for developers
to get started with it.
So I think it's
publicly available,
but not-- I think
it's like whatever
the open source version of
alpha would be considered.
We have a package called
Wide and Deep which
provides a higher level
abstraction on top
of TensorFlow that
allows you to say,
I have sparse features,
learn these sparse features.
Or, I have dense features,
learn these dense features.
And so it's very--
all you really
have to know about is
what your data looks like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, cool.
So how do I know if
TensorFlow is good for me?
What are the typical use
cases where the answer
is that, oh yeah, TensorFlow.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, so
we hope to expand it
to a lot of different machine
learning applications.
I think in particular if
you have a problem that's
well-suited to deep
learning, TensorFlow
is a great solution for you.
Again, deep learning
algorithms, they
require a huge amount
of data to train,
more so than many other
machine learning algorithms.
So you need to have that
at least somewhat available
to you.
MARK MANDEL: What's
a good heuristic
for a large amount of data?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, I think
the ballpark lower level is
maybe like 100,000 labeled is
common, for example, for text.
Yeah, text or image.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
you mentioned this label.
Does that mean that your
data needs to be labeled?
Actually, what does it
mean to be labeled and do
you need that?
ELI BIXBY: So we
commonly break down usage
of deep learning into two
different parts, training
and inference.
And so training is running
this TensorFlow graph
on your label data, and using it
to generate the proper weights.
And then inferences, you
have this unlabeled data
where you want to
predict the label,
and so you're giving that to
the trained TensorFlow graph
and it's spitting out a
probability for the label.
MARK MANDEL: So
when you say a label
it's kind of like, all right,
I've got a bunch of data
wherein, I don't
know, pick an example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
have a bunch of emails
and you need to know
if it's spam or not.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that works.
That's great.
So you know whether it's
spam, and so you can feed that
through the system and be
like, yes, these are spam,
these aren't.
And it could be like,
yay, now I'm learning.
And then at the end when
you're doing your inference
you can hand it an e-mail and
it will tell you whether or not
it's spam with I guess
some degree of certainty.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, e-mail
is a perfect example
because then you have a bunch of
users essentially providing you
with labels.
They click the
Report Spam button
and, bam, you have another
labeled piece of data.
And there's increasing
levels of sophistication,
but that's sort of the basics
is like, I have this label,
I want to predict the
label of something else.
So maybe you have a confidence
cut off and you're like,
oh, my model is not very
confident about this piece
of spam so I'm going to
surface it to the user.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You were
mentioning something before,
which I thought
it was very cool.
It was the one with
Reddit sub-Reddits.
ELI BIXBY: Yes, so we gave we
gave a talk at OSCON and PyCon
where we made a little
example algorithm based
on some colleagues' work
with tax classification,
and we used it to
classify Reddit post
titles by sub-Reddit.
And we got, I think, a
pretty good accuracy.
Not state of the art, but
I think it was mid 90s.
And yeah, these
are topics that are
very well suited because there's
large data sets available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's talk
about that specific example.
How does it look for a
developer to do that?
Imagine that I
have all the titles
and what sub-Reddit
they belong to.
What is the next step?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah,
so there's going
to be a pre-processing
set up, and we frequently
use Apache Beam to
pre-process our data.
And so then once
you have your data
in sort of this
nice vector format,
you can go and grab and try
to adapt for your use case
one of the many open source--
there's many models already
out there.
So frequently, you'll try
to figure out, what category
does my problem fit into?
OK, it's a text
classification problem.
Oh great, someone's already
written a text classification
model.
And then you'll try training
that model on your data
with your pre-process
data, and then
you'll do some testing
and some validation
and say, OK this worked,
this didn't work,
let me tinker around with
the model a little bit
until you get sort of an
accuracy you're happy with.
MARK MANDEL: Let's sort of
take an even further step back.
OK, so you say model.
What is does that input and
output look like with a model?
How does that work together?
ELI BIXBY: So
TensorFlow graphs are
defined with this Python code.
So TensorFlow is like
a Python package.
You write operations,
and an operation
will typically
have arguments that
are previous operations
you've defined.
So in this way, you're
defining the directed graph.
So there's two parts.
There's the graph
definition, and then
there's the training step
where you're running through,
basically, a loop saying, OK,
grab a batch of my training
data, run it through the graph.
It'll calculate gradients.
It will update the
operations on each node,
like we were talking about.
And then do that
until we're satisfied
with whatever accuracy
we're getting,
or whatever loss we're getting.
Whatever function we've
decided is our metric.
And then that will
constitute a model.
And then there are also lots
of [INAUDIBLE] or packages
that we've open-sourced.
So for example,
TensorFlow serving
allows you to serve models.
So do inference,
that's the other half.
So you'll export a
model, which is exporting
these weights and
this graph to a file,
and then TensorFlow serving
can load it for you,
and then provide you
an API, a gRPC API
where you can say-- you
can call it with a vector
and it will return
back the output
vector that you'd expect.
Maybe the labels.
MARK MANDEL: So if I was taking,
say, like a Reddit title,
and I'm going to convert
that into a vector, what
does that vector look like?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, so that's--
I talked a little bit about
before, without
explaining myself,
about sparse data
and dense data.
So like a Reddit--
maybe a Reddit title
is a list of vectors
where each vector is
your entire vocabulary.
So maybe 40,000 words
in the English language,
or whatever, and
there's a 1 somewhere
in there corresponding to
the word cat, is a one.
And maybe cat is like
the 30,250th word.
So like that 30,250th index
in your vector is a 1,
and everything else is 0s.
So that's sparse data.
Frequently in deep learning
we'll do embeddings.
So we'll try to learn denser
representations of data,
because the neural nets
tend to handle these denser
representations better.
So, and this is something we
talked about in our workshop,
words actually lend
themselves very well
to this dense embedding.
So you may actually
already have a model.
So there may be,
if you look at-- so
we open sourced
SyntaxNet, for example,
which is a piece of Google's
natural language processing
written in TensorFlow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But wasn't
it called Parsey McParseface?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, so there's
a subtle difference here.
We open sourced two things.
We open sourced SyntaxNet,
which is the graph definition,
and then we open sourced a
trained model, so including
the weights and all
the trained bits,
called Parsey
McParceface which was
trained on a subset of
the data that we have.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
ELI BIXBY: And so if
you look at SyntaxNet,
it's actually a bunch
of trained pieces,
a bunch of different neural
nets that feed into each other.
So there's this sense
of composability, which
brings me back to embedding.
So you may have a model that
somebody else has already
written for generating
word embeddings, where
you feed in your one hot vector
and it gives you back a denser
representation of words.
So maybe what you're
learning is a mapping
from these word embeddings
to sub-Reddit classification.
And so that's part of what we
hope to spur by this ecosystem
is this sense of
composability and other people
taking their models
and using them
as pieces of their own
models, and then providing
those models as pieces
for other people to use,
and just sort of building
this whole ecosystem.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
we've been talking models,
and that basically you're going
to be training some neural net
where you create that
model, and then that model
is a valuable piece of
information that you can use.
How big is a model?
ELI BIXBY: Oh man, I think
it varies a huge amount.
I'm not even sure how well
I can give a ballpark.
I think it depends a huge
amount on the variables,
like the size.
Like if we had a
vocabulary of 50 words,
and we were doing-- or, not
a vocabulary of 50 words.
If we were doing an embedding
in a vector of 50 length
that's going to be a much
smaller file than an embedding
of a vector of 100 length.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Are we
talking gigabytes here?
Terabytes?
ELI BIXBY: I think we
can be talking gigabytes.
Smaller models I think
may be under that,
but definitely-- I think
probably not a terabyte.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so it's
going to be quite a--
ELI BIXBY: On the
order of gigabytes.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
if I want to sit down
and I'm like, all right,
this thing sounds super cool,
it sounds super
interesting, how would I
get started with TensorFlow?
Where is a good place to start?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah,
so TensorFlow.org
has a bunch of great
tutorials that the brain
team has provided.
MNIST is kind of the
hello world of TensorFlow.
So that's this problem
that's been around
for a long time where you
have handwritten digits,
and you want to classify
them to the correct number.
And so I think that's sort of
the first place to get started,
and there's an
MNIST for beginners
and there's an MNIST
for ML experts.
So it'll walk you through what
is MNIST, why is it important,
here's a little bit of the math
behind the state of the art
MNIST algorithms if
you're a beginner.
And if not it will be just like,
here's TensorFlow and here's
how it corresponds to
the MNIST algorithm
that you're familiar with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Also, since you
mentioned that workshop
that you gave at
OSCON and PyCon,
that was like three
hours and it is online.
Could you recommend
that as an entry point
to someone that has
never done TensorFlow?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah, we tried to
make it pretty accessible.
I think even three
hours, It's kind of
hard to fit in a
comprehensive intro,
and so I think that
it's a little squashed.
But certainly you
should check that out.
And even if it's just
for the resource slides,
we have a lot of
resource slides in there
to sort of get you
started on your own.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, that
sounds very interesting.
We're kind of
running out of time.
Is there anything else
that you would like
to mention before we finish?
ELI BIXBY: Not off
the top of my head.
Definitely check out TensorFlow.
It's worth a look.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One
last question, actually.
What is the best use
case of TensorFlow?
The most fun usage of
TensorFlow you've ever seen?
ELI BIXBY: So I love DCGAN's,
which is some crazy acronym,
but generative adversarial
network is the last bit.
So it's actually two
neural nets that are
competing against each other.
One of them is
trying to classify
the output of the first
one and your training data,
and the other one is trying to
generate from noise things that
look like your training data.
And so you're training
this neural network
to trick this other
neural network, basically.
And so you generate-- there's
a bunch of hilarious pictures
in the paper and in the
GitHub of generated bedrooms,
and there they're like
uncanny valley bedrooms.
There are things that
look almost like bedrooms
but there is something
wrong about them,
and there's generated
faces and they're
like uncanny valley faces.
They're almost faces.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, we're
going to add a link to that
and I'm going to
definitely check it out.
It sounds very fun.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Eli, thank you
so much for joining us today.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah,
thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
So thank you to Eli for such
an interesting conversation.
Before we move to
the next topic I
wanted to add a
couple of corrections
that he actually gave as
soon as we stopped recording.
One of them, we asked him how
big TensorFlow models are,
and he said, probably
around gigabyte.
And turns out, it's
more like megabyte.
And he said that the
problem is that he's not
used to counting
that low anymore
since he works at Google.
Kind of humblebrag.
But yeah, it's actually
megabyte so you
can consider sending
them to your mobile phone
or having them as part of your
app, which is pretty cool.
And then something that
is not a correction
but I wanted to add anyway is
he mentioned Apache Beam, which
is actually something you can
run on Google Cloud Platform,
on Google Cloud data flow.
And also TensorFlow, you
can run it-- or you'll
be able to run it
soon, because it's
a limited preview for
now-- on Google Cloud
ML, ML standing for machine
learning, obviously.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so let's go
with the question
of the week, and I
think it comes from-- you
got the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: I did get
the question of the week.
It was from some people I
was chatting with this week,
and they were
talking about how say
you have 10 terabytes,
15 terabytes,
20 terabytes of data
sort of lying around.
Maybe on an [INAUDIBLE], maybe
on a hard drive, maybe running
on prem, something like that.
And you want to move everything
over to Google Cloud platform
and you're like,
this is going to take
me a really long
time to upload if I
have to do it over the wire.
So what do I do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You encode it
into XML, and then-- no, no.
So there's one option which
is you can use DS [INAUDIBLE]
and just start sending that
file through the network,
and that's going to
take very long time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
weeks, months.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
like long, long, long time.
So instead of doing that
there's a couple options,
and one of them was the
one that you mentioned.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so we
have a couple of partners,
one of which is Iron
Mountain for US areas,
and the other one is Prime Focus
Technologies for EMEA and APAC.
Pretty much is, yeah, you
can take a hard drive,
bundle it up, stick it on
a courier like FedEx or UPS
and send it directly
to them, and they'll
load it up for you quick smart.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that is actually-- yeah,
I think that Eli mentioned that.
That there's no wider band--
no, how do you say it?
MARK MANDEL: What?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
band is bandwidth.
There you go.
There's no connection
with higher bandwidth
that the mail-- like post mail.
You just send it and
we receive it-- well,
our partners receive
it and upload it,
and they appear directly
onto Google Cloud storage.
So that is probably one
of the fastest options.
But I wanted to
add one more, which
is what if you really want
to make these very fast
and all the time?
Like what if it's not
that you're sending--
you have 10 terabytes and
you have to send them once,
but you keep on generating
10 terabytes per day,
and you want to
send that as soon
as possible onto
your Google Cloud.
And there's a solution for that.
It's what we call Google
Cloud interconnect.
And basically what
you get is rather
than having public internet
connection from your data
center to ours, you going to get
very, very, very good quality
connection.
I think they use the term
enterprise grade, which I'm not
really sure what that means, but
I'm assuming it's really fast.
And it connects directly
from your data center
to Google's network edge.
MARK MANDEL: So
this would be if you
had like a sort of on prem
Cloud mix up type deal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, basically
I could imagine something
like that where
for instance you're
doing something like very, very
intense data, like big data,
and you're generating
a huge amount of data,
and you want to send
it directly to be
queried or something like that.
And in that case, if you have
such a huge amount of data
you need to send it somehow,
and maybe sending disks via mail
is not good enough.
So in that case, you can go
through Cloud Interconnect.
The pricing for
it, it's actually
something that
depends on the cases,
so you need to
contact a provider.
I guess it depends on how
far away you live from a data
center, stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: No, that
sounds really cool.
Like maybe you have
requirements that
mean you have to be on
prem for various things.
Like your app has
to be there, but you
want to use our big
data tools and you
want to be able to
send that data through.
That sounds really good.
But no, that's
cool, and you know,
the whole sending of hard
drives via UPS or FedEx
could be the one time thing
you do if you're moving over
to the Cloud.
If you're on prem, and you want
to make that shift as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, cool, well
I think we're pretty much
done with the episode.
But I'm curious about what are
you going to be up to next week
and after that.
MARK MANDEL: So I am staying in
San Francisco for the next week
and a half, but I will
be off to New York
after that for a panel
at a play crafting event
we'll be holding in
the New York offices.
So that will be lots
of fun, and then
after that I'm
hanging around in San
Francisco for a little while,
so I think I'm pretty good.
What are you up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So next week
I'm going to Los Angeles again.
This time I'm flying,
so it should be faster.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, and I'm going
to be giving a talk at Los-- I
think the name is Los Angeles
Gophers meet up.
It's the Go meet up in LA.
So basically, it's
going to be kind
of my rehearsal for GopherCon.
And then in the
second week of July
I'll be a GopherCon
in Denver, Colorado.
And that's pretty much it.
Then after that I think
holidays are deserved.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Well Francesc,
thank you once more
for joining me for this
weekly episode of the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you very much, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank you
very much to all our listeners
for paying attention once more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]